c'est sans surprise que le sénat a
rejeté jeudi 18 février l'amendement
déposé par le gouvernement pour
autoriser le vote par anticipation lors
de l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
on parle de ce sujet avec célia 200 go
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78 quel
était l'objet de cet amendement et bien
selon marlène schiappa 1 la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté les électeurs
auraient pu voter de manière anticipée
sur des machines à voter durant la
semaine précédant le scrutin dans des
bureaux et aline date qui restait à
définir par décret alors l'amendement et
vous l'avez dit a définitivement
entériné par le sénat pour en tout cas
l'élection de 2022
qu'est ce que concrètement le vote par
anticipation c'est bien alors le système
de vote par anticipation peut prendre
différentes formes en fonction des dates
lieux et échéance décidée par la
constitution
par exemple le scrutin prévu le dimanche
peut commencer très bien le délai
mercredi et s'étaler du coup jusqu'à la
date officielle
alors ces votes anticipés peuvent être
effectués via une machine électronique
ou par papier par voie postale ce qui
correspond finalement au vote par
correspondance loi supprimé en 1975 et
nous avons voulu demander ce que pensent
les yvelinois du vote par anticipation
je préfère me rendre dans l'urne ou
pouvoir anticiper à plusieurs semaines
ou plusieurs mois oui parce qu'on ne
sait pas encore aujourd'hui quelles
seront les conditions sanitaires on
présente la carte
on insère la petite enveloppe ndi a voté
la clk chez tout ça non mais j'aime bien
ça serait plus rapide
pour nous qui travaillons en fait trop
et ça serait pas mal
à part pour les gestes barrière où ça
pourrait permettre justement qui ait
moins de monde dans les bureaux de vote
sinon je trouve pas ça super utile on
trafique abl on pourrait facilement
entrer chez moi ça c'est partagé il ya
aussi eu de vives réactions dans les
différentes oppositions politiques
oui oui le vote par anticipation a
suscité un tollé dans la sphère
politique
alors d'abord dans la forme par le
caractère soudain de cet amendement mais
aussi dans le fond puisque tous les
partis d'opposition sont contre écouter
on ne touche pas à la règle pendant le
processus
on est dans la dernière ligne droite de
la fin du mandat des manuels battre on
ne change pas les règles cette manière
là avec cette méthode sans débat
national sans débat citoyen et sans
consensus politique
comme tous les élus heures ne sont pas
forcément au même niveau d'information
on n'est pas sûr de la qualité
d'électeur est ce que c'est bien lui qui
vote dans les élections américaines cela
suscitait un doute importante ce vote
par anticipation ne permettra pas une
transparence comme on en a l'habitude
dans la comptabilité et la vérification
des votes
je ne crois qu'il faut rien s'interdire
qu'il faut vraiment réfléchir à toutes
les pistes qu'il faut être complètement
ouvert bon je fais pas comme ça dans la
précipitation cc c'est dangereux pour la
démocratie
vous l'aurez compris il ya beaucoup de
doutes concernant le vote par
anticipation la majorité elle voulait le
mettre en place pour lutter contre
l'abstention
ça sera un obstacle levé pour les
personnes qui peuvent pas se déplacer le
dimanche il y apprend le monde et les
éléments discutable qu'on peut on peut
compenser mais parlant gens ne nous
interdisons pas le débat sous un
prétexte et de logique de on est contre
le débat est maintenant ouvert en tout
cas dans la sphère publique et pour
rappel le vote par correspondance avait
été supprimé en 1975 pour réduire la
fraude électorale
questionnement le similaire pour le vote
par anticipation